The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, good afternoon.
So this week we talk
about quantum gases,
ultra-cold atomic gases.
And sure, they're ideal Bose
gases, ideal Fermi gases,
but I will spend one
or two minutes on each,
because that's exactly solvable.
It's in all the textbooks.
That's simple.
Quantum gases become interesting
because of interactions.
And in my lecture today
and my last lecture
I want to introduce you
to Bose gases and Fermi
gases with inter actions.
And they both turn superfluid,
and the superfluid properties
are determined by the
interactions between the atoms.
So the purpose of those
lectures is number one,
to acquaint to you with
important phenomena
in cold gases-- superfluidity,
superfluidity in lattices,
superfluidity just in
free gas, in a normal gas
without lattice, and
superfluidity of fermions.
But at the same
time, I also want
to have sort of a theme for you
how we deal with interactions.
And that kind of theme
is how theoretically we
reduce unsolvable
Hamiltonians to Hamiltonians
which can be solved.
And you will see that
actually appearing
in different situations
with similarities,
but important differences.
So just to remind
you, we started out
with the interacting Bose
gas in a homogeneous system.
We have a very general
way to describe
scattering two particles with
initial momentum disappear
and two particles
with momenta appear.
This is a scattering event.
Now this means we have products
of four operators, which
is very difficult to solve.
And the Bogoliubov approximation
which we discussed on Monday
replaces the operator for
the condensate for the zero
momentum state with a Z number,
saying that N 0, N 0 plus 1
is the same-- a little
bit waving your hands.
But it's also you can say
the macroscopic limit when
we have a photon field
with many, many photons,
we can use a Z number
in our Hamiltonian
to describe the electric field.
So that's the same spirit.
So maybe I should emphasize it.
This is for atoms.
What you're used to do with
photons for your whole life.
OK.
With that we have
transformed the Hamiltonian
into a bilinear expression.
And so at the moment your
bilinear expression--
you do a Bogoliubov
transformation.
You simply diagonalize it by
finding a new set operators
where the cross term
between a and b or between a
of k and a of minus k disappear.
And then you've solved it.
And this is what we arrived at
at the end of the last lecture.
With those
approximations, we have
diagonalized the Hamiltonian.
Our Hamiltonian is now, you
can say harmonic oscillator
Hamiltonian, or
you can see it has
become a gas of non-interacting
quasi particles.
Each of those operators
creates a quasi particle,
and the quasi particle
energy is U of k.
And I explained to
you that as expected,
the quasi particle
energy is simply
particles with momentum
h-bar k for high momenta,
because in high excitation
of Bose quantums
it is a free particle.
But a low-lying excitation
is affected in a major way
by all of these
interactions with
the Bose-Einstein condensate.
And that turns the quadratic
dispersion relation
into a linear one,
or you can say
that turns the free particle
into a photon or something.
So that's my review
of the last class.
Are there any questions
before we go further?
Colin.
AUDIENCE: Does this require
low density and [INAUDIBLE],
or one or the other?
PROFESSOR: We come a little bit
later to that, but in the end,
there is a small parameter.
The small parameter will be N
a cubed-- the gas parameter--
N, the density, a cubed,
the scattering length.
It's usually the dimensionless
combination of the two
which decides whether we are
in the weakly or strongly
interacting limit.
There is another assumption
which we have made here,
but it's related to that-- as
you will see a few moments--
that most of the are
in the condensate.
We assumed N0 is peak.
The condensate depletion-- the
number of atoms which are not
in the condensate,
t equals 0 is small.
But let me just
first show you-- I
want to mix in
theory and experiment
how sound can be observed.
I should actually say this
experiment is sort of dear
to my heart, because
at some point
it clicked to me how the
new world of atomic physics
connects with condensed
matter physics.
Soon after we had realized
Bose-Einstein condensates,
a famous condensed matter
theorist said hey, Wolfgang,
you should now observe sound.
Sound is important.
Yeah, OK, but how do
you observe sound?
You know, use a piezo
and just kick the system
and create a sound wave.
And I said, oh, gosh, this
guy doesn't know with that
if you put anything in contact
with the quantum gases--
a piezo-- the gases
will just stick to it.
He has no idea
what our system is.
But then I said wait a
moment-- we have to translate.
He says use a piezo.
Well, I have to translate.
In atomic physics
how do we kick atoms?
With a laser beam.
And in that moment,
I had the idea
that we can take a
Bose-Einstein condensate,
suddenly switch on a blue
de-tuned repulsive laser beam.
This will do exactly as a
piezo-- create a density
perturbation, and then
the density perturbation
will propagate with
the speed of sound.
And that worked.
That was just when Bose-Einstein
condensations were very fresh.
One of the first
scientific experiments
done-- we switch on
the laser and you
see color-coded in red the
density perturbation which
propagates out of it.
And the slope of this line
is the speed of sound.
And here we determined
the speed of sound
as a function of density.
So that's how phonons--
or at least how
the speed of sound
and wave packets which
propagate with the speed
of sound can be prepared.
I come back to phonons
and collective excitations
in a few moments.
But let me first say
when we have diagonalized
the Hamiltonian we know
everything we want to know.
I just focused on the
quasi particle energies,
but you also know the
ground-state energy.
And actually here Colin,
you see that the corrections
to the ground-state
energy scale with N
a cubed, so this is really the
small parameter in this system.
But we can also find out what is
the ground state wave function.
And let me use it to introduce
an important concept to you
called the quantum depletion.
When you have two atoms in the
condensator at zero momentum
and you switch on
the interactions,
the delta function interaction
couples zero momentum state
to higher momentum states.
So therefore, the
effect of interactions
is that the condensate is
not just at zero momentum.
It has some probability,
or some admixture,
of finite momentum states.
This is the ground state.
This is how the Hamiltonian
is diagonalized.
So from the Bogoliubov
approximation,
where we introduced
this V and U parameter
to transfer from one
set of Bose operators
to another set of
Bose operators,
those coefficients
give us the population
of those momentum states in the
[INAUDIBLE] of the condensate.
So if I now ask, what is
the condensate fraction?
What is the number of atoms
in the zero momentum states?
It's all atoms, but those
who have finite momentum.
And we find again the
small parameter N a cubed.
Now this quantum
depletion allows me now
to make a distinction
between the cold atomic gas
condensates and
superfluid helium form.
In cold atomic gas condensates,
this correction is about 1%.
So therefore, I can say
with 99% probability,
or with 99% weight,
the condensate,
the many-body wave
function of the condensate
is just the zero momentum
state to the power N.
And this very complicated
admixture of correlation
into the ideal gas wave function
is only 1% for alkali gases.
But for liquid helium,
the condensate fraction--
even at zero
temperature-- is only 10%.
So when people use
neutron scattering--
it would be a long story in
itself how this is done--
but when they use neutron
scattering to analyze
the liquid helium
at low temperature,
and figure out what is the
fraction of atoms which
have zero momentum,
they found 10%.
The quantum depletion is 90%.
But that's just the
difference between a quantum
gas and a quantum liquid.
And in the quantum liquid--
in liquid helium-- N
a cubed is on the
order of unity.
OK, I mentioned this
dispersion relation.
These are sort of
quasi particles.
And I at least
showed you how you
can measure the slope of the
quasi particle dispersion
relation by propagating
sound waves.
But let me now tell you how we
can observe quasi particles'
elementary excitations directly.
And this is actually simply
done by light scattering.
If you scatter a photon,
and the scattered photon
loses energy h-bar U. And
it is scattered at an angle.
Therefore, it
transfers momentum q.
These forces can
only happen if there
is an elementary excitation
with momentum q and energy h U.
So in other words,
on a photon basis,
you can see photon
by photon, if you
scatter a photon, the photon
transfers momentum and energy.
The process can only happen if
you can form a quasiparticle
with this momentum and energy.
So since this is sort of the
direct way of mapping out
whether the system
has the possibility
to absorb momentum q and energy
h nu, this has sort of a name.
The scattering probability is
called the dynamic structure
factor.
And the dynamic structure
factor is just an integral
over all the possibilities
that a many-body system can
absorb momentum and energy.
Now there is one
nice feature which
was introduced by
us at MIT, and that
is if you're going to measure
the dynamic structure factor,
often you do it with
neutron scattering.
You scatter neutrons or x-rays
and they scatter spontaneously
at an angle, and
you need a detector
to detect the
scattered particles.
But in our case, because
the gas is so dilute,
the distance between
atoms is on the order
of the optical wavelengths.
We don't want neutrons.
We don't want x-rays.
We want photons, because
the wavelengths of photons
is perfectly matched
to the properties,
to momentum transfer and
such we need for our system.
But photons-- we
have photon lasers.
So instead of in a painstakingly
way analyzing the frequency
and the momentum of
scattered photons,
we don't do the spontaneous
scattering process.
We do a stimulated process.
We use two laser beams,
and we stimulate a photon
to be scattered into
the other laser beam.
And by having the two laser
beams at frequency difference
delta omega, we're
really asking the system,
are you ready to absorb
delta omega energy?
If yes, then you
have a quasiparticle.
So this is how we do
quasiparticle spectroscopy.
And a few years
later, this method
was defined by the
[INAUDIBLE] Institute.
And what you see
here is they varied
the angles between the
two laser beams, realized
different momentum
transfer, and what
you see is the low dispersion,
the linear dispersion
relation for low
momenta, and then
the quadratic part
at high momentum.
So this is called
BEC spectroscopy.
It's a variant, you can see,
of Raman spectroscopy where
you go from a zero quasiparticle
state to a one quasiparticle
state through a
simulated Raman process,
and this is how the dispersion
relation is determined.
OK so I've so far
dealt with aspects
of a homogeneous Bose-Einstein
condensate where,
of course, if you're
a homogeneous system,
you formulate everything
in momentum space.
But now we want to
deal with the situation
that our condensates
are finite in size.
And in addition, they're
usually in a harmonic oscillator
potential, and therefore their
density is inhomogeneous.
Let me start the discussion with
the inhomogeneous Bose-Einstein
condensate by showing
again a picture which
brings in some
memories of '90, '96.
It was the first
time that we could
see the Bose-Einstein
condensate in the trap.
Before people have just
seen it by time of flight
when it was pretty
much already destroyed
or it was just flying out.
But here we see the trapped
Bose-Einstein condensate
and we could even
take multiple pictures
of the same condensate.
So you can see that
this was the first time
that a condensate
was seen alive.
What you see here is actually
the bimodal distribution.
You see the condensate and
then due to speckled pattern,
the Fermi cloud
looks fragmented,
but this is just a
speckled pattern due
to the signal to noise.
But here you really see now--
not in ballistic expansion
as I showed you on Monday--
but really insight to the size
and shape of the condensate.
OK, how do we describe it?
Well, the message is pretty
much exactly the same way
as we did with the Bogoliubov
approximation and such,
but instead of in
momentum space,
we do it now in position space.
Actually, I have
to say this week,
I go through a lot of material.
But what I'm trying
is to give you
sort of a spirited
and animated overview
that you really know
what is important.
Where is the same
concept appearing again
in a different way.
The details-- I've
posted, actually,
the original
articles, references.
Some of are school
notes, some of them
written by myself
on the backside.
So yes, it's a little
bit different character
than other lectures.
I want to show you
a lot of things,
and put a special
emphasis on the ideas.
OK, so in second
quantization, we
are now using field operators
which create and annihilate
particles at position R.
This is the single particle
Hamiltonian-- kinetic
energy and potential energy.
And our interaction term has
now, again, four operators--
two interrelation operators,
two creation operators,
but they're now formulated
in position space.
We do exactly the same as we
did in the homogeneous gas.
We assume the potential
is short range.
That means delta function.
And that means we
can get rid of one
of the integrations
in r and r prime.
But we still have product
of four operators.
We can formally solve the
equation by writing down
Heisenberg's situation for the
equation of motion for those
field operators, but of
course this cannot be solved.
Remember products are
four operators are hard.
We have to reduce
it to two operators.
And this is actually done by the
Bogoliubov approximation again.
But it's done here
in the following way.
Remember, in the momentum space
we replaced a0 and a0 dagger
by the square root of a0.
What we do here is we say this
is sort of a quantum field.
And when we have a superfluid,
this field operator
has an average value.
It's actually the macroscopic
superfluid order parameter.
So we replace the operator
by an average value
which we assume is large,
because many, many particles
are in the superfluid state.
And then we have
fluctuations which are small.
And what we will do is-- it's
pretty clear-- when it comes
to the fluctuations, we will
neglect higher products--
products of four
fluctuation operators.
And we are down to C
numbers and, as you
will see, two operators.
We can-- and this is
even more dramatic--
it wouldn't make sense
in momentum space,
but it does make sense
in position space--
we can even do a
first approximation
where we completely
neglect those fluctuations.
And then what we have
is when we simply
insert a [? Z ?] number
into this Hamiltonian.
We have then an equation
for this number,
for this function psi.
And this is the nonlinear
Schrodinger equation,
or it's also called
Gross-Pitaevskii equation,
which is now the analogy
to Schrodinger's equation,
but now for the macroscopic
wave function which
is occupied by many,
many particles.
And in addition to
the kinetic energy
and the trapping potential
in the external potential,
it has a term which is
proportional to the density.
And this is just
mean field repulsion
which one atom feels
exerted by the other atoms.
I should say--
just to connect it
to what I've said earlier
about the quantum depletion--
that you can regard the
function psi as the best
approximation to an ideal
Bose-Einstein condensate.
So if you want to write
your many-body wave
function as a function
psi to the power N,
all particles are in
the same quantum state,
then a variational
calculation would
say that this function psi
should obey this equation.
If you want to read
up what I've said,
I've posted a recent paper,
which I found very pedagogical,
where they derive the
Gross-Pitaevskii equation
without even using an
operator psi dagger,
without using any
second quantization.
They just say we have an
Hamiltonian for an interaction
system, and we try to write
the complicated, many-body wave
function as a wave
function to the power N.
And then you put this
ansatz into your Hamiltonian
and do a variation optimization
which single-particle wave
function psi, if
taken to the power N,
minimizes the total
energy of N particles,
including interactions.
And the answer is this equation.
So there are many
ways this equation
is sort of very natural.
Now you all know about
single-particle physics--
kinetic energy in an
external potential.
Let's now learn what this
density-dependent term does.
Well, it's pretty clear.
There is a price to
be paid for density.
And while the total
integrated density, of course,
is given by the total
number of particles.
That means if you lower
the density somewhere,
you have to increase
the density.
But because this is
a non-linear term,
if you have an average
density and you lower it
here and increase it here, you
have actually more repulsive
energy than if the
density is flat.
So this term has only one goal.
It wants to flatten
out densities.
So therefore if we
have a box potential
and you know the
ground state in a box
is just half a period
of a sine function.
This is a non-interacting
condensate.
This would be the
macroscopic wave
function in a box potential.
But if you now put in
strong interactions,
the strong interaction's going
to flatten out the potential.
They flatten out the
potential, and only at the very
last moment-- all
right, now it's
time to go down because we have
to meet our boundary condition.
And the length scale where
you eventually go down-- it
has a famous name,
the healing length--
is the length scale
where the kinetic energy
due to the curvature
of the wave function
is now comparable to
the interaction energy.
If the system would
curve down earlier,
it would cause too
much repulsive energy,
because the density
is not kept flat.
If it would curve down too
late, the enormous curvature
would mean a lot
of kinetic energy.
And this is just
the best compromise
between those two criteria.
So that's how you derive
the healing length.
The healing length is
now the length scale
over which the system is willing
to meet boundary conditions,
and not stay flat,
as flat as possible.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Just curious--
in that equation,
the atom has the mass
of each individual--
PROFESSOR: The mass is
the mass of a single atom.
AUDIENCE: Single atom,
it's not-- sorry,
I wasn't here last time.
But the quasiparticles are
the same mass [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: In a Bose-Einstein
condensate they are.
We haven't changed the mass.
But we're not talking
actually about quasiparticle.
We're actually really talking
about here qualitative features
of the solution of the
Gross-Pitaevskii equation.
And the Gross-Pitaevskii
equation
is sort of a single particle
equation for particles of mass,
of the original bare mass
M. It's a macroscopic wave
function, but I sometimes say
it describes the wave function
of a single particle where
all the other particles are
included at the
mean field level.
So therefore, it is really
this, the atomic mass,
and not any form of
collective mass here.
Well, if you would now
ask how do interactions
transform the first excited
state in the box potential?
Well, then it's again flat
this as much as possible.
But then if you want to
maintain the parity of the wave
function, then it's
only close to the zero
crossing within a healing length
that the system says OK, now I
change sign.
So that's sort of what is inside
the Gross-Pitaevskii equation.
Now once we realize that, we
can take it to the next level
and say, well, if you
neglect-- let's say
we're interested
in the ground state
and we neglect this
boundary region where
the kinetic energy
becomes important-- maybe
we can simplify the
Gross-Pitaevskii equation
by neglecting the
kinetic energy.
If potential energy dominates
by far, we can neglect that.
And then we should
get a good description
which will not be valid in
the wings of the wave function
but in most of space.
But now if you look
at this equation,
it's no longer a
differential equation.
It has no derivatives.
It's just something
which applies
to the wave function psi itself.
And we can simply solve that.
The solution of that
is that psi squared--
the density-- is
nothing else than there
is a constant minus the
inverted trapping potential.
So therefore in this
Thomas-Fermi approximation
where we neglect the
kinetic energy completely,
you just take your trapping
potential, turn it upside down,
and then you fill
it up with density
until you have accommodated
the number of atoms
you want to accommodate.
And this is, of
course-- the constraint
in the number of atoms is
determined by the chemical
potential.
Or if you have a more
complicated W-shaped potential,
the same construction.
Flip it over, fill it up,
gives you the condensate wave
function, the
density distribution
of the condensate
in this potential.
I don't want to belabor
it, but coming back
to the question of
the small parameter,
if you look at
those equations, you
can identify a parameter-- this
is now the small parameter,
or the parameter
in the system which
is the important
dimensionless parameter.
It depends on the
number of atoms,
and it depends now on the ratio
of the scattering length--
which characterizes
the interaction--
and the harmonic
oscillator length.
You can say the
harmonic oscillator
length is the ideal wave
function harmonic oscillator.
So this parametrizes the
importance of kinetic energy,
whereas the scattering
length parametrizes
the importance of interactions.
And all those solutions
can be nicely written
as what you would
have in an ideal gas,
and then this parameter X. So
in typical experiments, N a,
N is a million.
The scattering length is smaller
than the oscillator length,
but N is a million, and this
parameter X is usually large.
So therefore-- and I'm
simply just talking
about this solution-- we have
the situation that the chemical
potential is larger
by a power of X
than the ideal gas solution,
which would just be the ground
state with its zero point energy
in the harmonic oscillator
potential, or the width-- the
size-- of the wave function
is larger than the ground state
of the harmonic oscillator,
but only with an exponent,
which is one-fifth.
Well, we can see that.
These are now, again,
somewhat improved pictures
of condensates inside the trap.
For the expert, the
previous picture
was dark-ground imaging.
This is now
phase-contrast imaging.
And if you take a
profile, we clearly
see the condensate wave function
and we see the thermal wings.
When we look at the size of
the condensate wave function,
you realize what I just meant--
that the ground-state wave
function, the harmonic
oscillator length
is 7 micron in the
axial direction,
but here you have 300 micron.
So this condensate is completely
dominated by interactions.
And it fulfils very nice, and
pretty much the whole shape,
except maybe some
details in the wings,
are quantitatively described
by the simple approximation
I have explained to you.
So just a little
bit show and tell.
We have this
Gross-Pitaevskii equation.
The Gross-Pitaevskii equation
has, as Schrodinger's equation,
a time independent form
to get the ground state.
It has also a time
dependent form.
You simply replace the
energy by the derivative
of the wave function.
This is the time-dependent form.
Everything is very simple, and
you can do many-body physics,
but on your computer,
you pretty much look
for single-particle
wave function
and take them to the power N.
So some areas where the
Gross-Pitaevskii equation
has quantitatively
explained experiments-- one
is the expansion of a
Bose-Einstein condensate.
It's this famous
situation when you
have an elongated condensate
and let it expand.
It expands faster in
the radial direction.
One simple argument
is the pressure
of the mean field is larger and
leads to faster acceleration.
So therefore, if you have
a cigar-shaped condensate
and release it, it
turns into a disk.
It inverts the aspect ratio,
going from a cigar shape
to a disk shape.
And that has been beautifully
and quantitatively described
by the Gross-Pitaevskii
equation.
Here we have measured
the interaction energy
as a number of condensed atoms.
And I mentioned to you that
this X parameter comes often
with power 1/5 and 2/5.
And this here is a
fit to the power 2/5,
beautifully
confirming the theory.
So the Gross-Pitaevskii
equation was
invented in 1962, about 50 years
ago by Gross and Pitaevskii
to describe vortices.
Actually, Lev Pitaevskii
is still alive,
going strong, and
publishing papers.
One of his latest predictions
was solitons in Fermi gases,
and I know in Professor
Zwierlein's group,
one of his lab just looked
at the same physics,
and compared to the
theory of Lev Pitaevskii.
And this year we
are celebrating--
I forgot, the 85th or
90th birthday of him.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: 90?
AUDIENCE: There's a poster.
PROFESSOR: I know there's
a poster next to my door,
but I forgot which anniversary.
So I mean, he's an legend.
But he's still walking.
He's still doing science.
So if you meet him, you go
back to 50 years in history.
Anyway, it is this
Lev Pitaevskii,
and he invented his equations
to describe vortices.
So anyway so we have this
nonlinear Schrodinger equation.
Let me just show you
what vortices are
and how they are formed.
Vortices come-- if you solve
the Gross-Pitaevskii equation--
if you ever any quantum
fluid or quantum gas,
and you add angular momentum,
the angular momentum cannot
lead to rigid body rotation.
This would violate the fact
that the velocity field has
to be irrotational to make
sure that the phase of the wave
function is well defined.
So if you rotate the system,
it can absorb angular momentum
only by forming vortices.
And vortices are singular points
of the wave function-- singular
points where the density is 0.
In other words-- I don't have
time to be exhaustive here--
but when something
rotates, there
is a dynamic phase you
can say, because there
are matter waves
going in circles.
And the integral
of the phase has
to be an integer number
of 2 pi, otherwise
you would not have a
well-defined phase of the wave
function.
And if you now say you make
a circle, which is 2 pi.
You make the circle
smaller, smaller, smaller.
In the middle of the
circle, you go around.
The wave function
changes by 2 pi,
but what should the wave
function do on one point?
Which number between 0 and 2 pi
should the wave function peak?
Well, the wave function
says I can't peak.
I just go to 0.
And a 0 value has no
phase and I'm fine.
That's exactly what the
wave function tells you.
So therefore if you want
to describe vortices,
you want to now describe the
Gross-Pitaevskii equation,
but with the boundary condition
that the wave function
goes to 0.
And if you want to
describe one vortex,
you want the wave function to
go 0 in the center of the cloud.
And so you make a
corresponding Ansatz.
You allow the phase to
wrap around by 2 pi,
when the angle phi is varied.
And then when you solve
it, you have, of course,
put in that there should be a
0 of the density at the center.
And it's now nice for me to--
there's an important review
paper which describes
all that and more--
but it's nice to
show you now the two
extreme cases of the ideal
condensate without interaction,
and the strong
interacting condensate.
The ideal condensate-- well, we
are in the first excited state
of the harmonic
oscillator potential.
And this is the dashed line.
And of course, the size
of the whole, the 0,
is pretty much on the order
of the oscillator length,
because there is no
other length scale
in the ideal
harmonic oscillator.
But if you have the
interacting system,
remember what
interactions are doing.
They want to keep the density
as constant as possible.
Well, we are not
in a box potential.
We're in an inverted
parabola potential.
And remember, our
Thomas-Fermi solution,
which neglects kinetic energy,
is the inverted parabola
up to here.
And then the tail is
when we can no longer
neglect the kinetic energy.
But if we now say, OK, fine,
but now in addition, we
want a vortex in
the center, the wave
function out there says no.
We do what minimizes
kinetic energy,
and what minimizes
repulsive energy.
We follow the inverted
parabola, and only
at the very last moment-- on
the scale of the healing length,
the system meets the
required boundary condition
that the density goes to 0.
Anyway, with this
qualitative understanding,
you can get a lot out of those.
You can immediately
understand the salient feature
of the solution.
Question?
AUDIENCE: I know we're
not talking details,
but is there a simple,
maybe clear reason why
when you spin a
Bose-Einstein condensate
you get many vortices, but
when you spin your coffee
in your cup, you
just get one big one?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So the question is, if I have
a wrap-around of 4 pi in phase,
whether the system should have
a doubly charged vortex, or two
singly charged vortices?
What is the
difference in energy?
Well, what happens is doubly
charged vortices are unstable.
My group, at some point,
were the first to create
doubly charged
vortices, but we saw
that they immediately decayed.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Initially,
we couldn't observe.
We just saw that
it was unstable.
But it's a decay
into two vortices.
But it's easy to understand.
If you put two vortices
on top of each other,
what is the energy of the
system compared to one vortex?
Well, the energy of a vortex is
the rotational field around it,
and if you superimpose
two vortices,
the velocity around the
doubly charged vortices
is twice the velocity
of one vortex.
And therefore, the kinetic
energy is four times.
If you have two
vortices which are
far separated that it has
its own velocity field.
It has its own
velocity field here.
And when the two velocity
fields come together,
the velocity is
already so low that you
don't have to consider that,
then those two vortices have
an energy which is two times
the energy of a single vortex.
So therefore, when
the two vortices,
they start out with four times
the energy of a single vortex,
and when they dissociate
and repel each other,
they have shed half
of their energy.
So this argument
tells you immediately
that vortices are
in effect repulsive.
And therefore, any
multiple-charged vortex
will spontaneously decay.
It's also this net
repulsion between vortices
which makes the vortices
arrange in a regular lattice.
The regular lattice
which you saw before
is Nature's answer to
how can we minimize
the energy of all
those vortices?
And the idea is let's keep the
average distance between them
as large as possible, and the
answer is a hexagonal lattice.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So a few
slides back, when
you write the G-P equation, when
you plotted sort of for the box
potential, the ground state
and the excited state comparing
the G-P equation to the typical
single-particle [INAUDIBLE].
And so I guess I'm a
little bit confused
about how excitations manifest
themselves in the system.
Because in some sense, if you
were to solve the G-P equation,
would you arrive at a
spectrum of solutions?
Then I guess I'd be confused
at whether excitations manifest
themselves into that
spectrum of solutions,
or rather than they become
excitations, sort of deviations
from the mean field as
including the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You are now
asking about something
more complicated.
You're asking what
are the excited
states of the many-body system?
And actually, we have
already found one answer.
And this is if you want
these small excitations,
it's one particle
becomes a phonon,
or one particle becomes
a quasiparticle.
What we are talking
about here is
what happens if the
whole macroscopic wave
function is in an excited state.
So we are asking here in
the box potential what
happens if you force all N atoms
to have one node in the wave
function.
And this is what I'm
talking about here.
So the excitation
energy of this state
here is much, much higher
than of single quasiparticle
excitations.
I'm not sure if I'm addressing
your question here, but--
AUDIENCE: So with
single quasiparticle
excitations, are
those essentially sort
of deviations from
the mean field?
PROFESSOR: No, they
are-- you really
look for many-body physics--
main field deviations--
probably.
I mean, what you do
is in that sense, yes.
You're allowing in this
Ansatz that psi operator
is psi average
plus fluctuations.
You now look for
fluctuations, and you're
looking for the
energy eigenspectrum
of those fluctuations.
And the answer are
quasiparticles.
So it is, actually,
the Bogoliubov solution
for the spectrum of
the fluctuations.
And the answer is the dispersion
relation I presented to you.
Whereas here we
are asking what are
excited states of the
macroscopic wave function?
It's a very, very
different question
which we've addressed here.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So when you
stir the condensate,
do you view it as-- do you
stir, sort of, at the trap
frequency, so I do sort
of N single excitations?
Or do you stir at N
times the trap frequency,
so you get one sort of
N particle excitation?
PROFESSOR: Well, the
experimental answer
is you want to stir at the
quadrupole frequency, which
is square root 2 times
the trap frequency.
Then you create
quadrupolar excitations.
The quadrupolar excitation can
be regarded as a standing sound
wave, but you create
a macroscopic number
of those excitations.
So you make, actually, the
whole condensate wave function
oscillate in a
quadrupolar pattern,
but it's a rotating
quadrupole, and that
eventually then rearranges
itself and leads to vortices.
So I think the correct answer
is the most efficient way
to create vortices would be to
excite quasiparticles, but then
create so many-- and this may
relate to Matt's question--
create so many quasiparticles
that you have really
a time-dependent and oscillating
macroscopic wave function.
So eventually, you have
a coherent excitation
of quasiparticles.
And that eventually means
the condensate moves
in a quadrupolar pattern, but
it's a quadrupolar pattern
with rotation, and
that eventually
turns into many vortices.
But that's really a very rich
question which you're asking,
which has been studied-- a lot
of different aspects of that
have been studied.
OK, so we've talked about
Bose-Einstein condensates
in a homogeneous system, just
sort of to lay the groundwork.
We've talked about
Bose-Einstein condensates
in traps in
inhomogeneous system.
Now we want to talk about
Bose-Einstein condensates
in optical lattices.
Well, there are two reasons
why we want to do that.
One is we want to use the
Bose-Einstein condensate
to obtain deeper insight into
the properties of matter.
And a lot of forms of matter
appear in periodic lattices.
So if you put a
Bose-Einstein condensate
into a periodic
potential, we can at least
understand some
of the properties
of crystalline
matter, or electrons
which are block waves
in a periodic potential.
So this is one reason why.
The other reason why we want
to go to optical lattices
is the following-- ideal
Bose-Einstein condensates
are trivial.
Weakly interacting Bose-Einstein
condensates are entertaining,
and you can write a lot of
papers, have a lot of fun
with it, develop your methods--
also mildly intellectually
interesting because how those
weak interactions manifest
itself in vortices and all.
It's really rich
and interesting.
But the conceptional
problems appear
when you go to
strong interactions.
Strongly correlated matter is
where mean field descriptions
no longer work.
This is really the frontier
of our understanding
of many-body systems.
And when you want
to be there, you
want to create a strongly
correlated system.
And strongly correlated systems
means that the interaction
energy dominates
over kinetic energy.
In Bose-Einstein
condensates you can only
go so far with
increasing interactions--
why are Feshbach resonances?
Because you get into some
inelastic collisions.
So that's one knob to turn.
You go to larger and larger
of scattering lengths,
and crank up the interactions.
But if atoms strongly interact,
they start to do bad chemistry.
They start to spin flip.
They do other things.
And in some cases you
keep it under control.
In others, you just can't
But another way to get
to strong interactions
means you reduce
the kinetic energy.
It's the ratio of the
two which matters.
And when you put particles
in a lattice, well,
the lattice actually
reduces the kinetic energy.
You may know from
condensed matter physics
that in a lattice there is
an effective mass, which
is higher than the
[INAUDIBLE] mass.
Therefore you've reduced
the kinetic energy.
Or if you want another
hand-waving approximation,
the kinetic energy is
given by the bandwidths.
And if the tunneling
becomes slower and slower,
the width of your
band becomes narrower,
and your kinetic energy is less.
So anyway, I can give you many
hand-waving approximations
why in a lattice,
kinetic energy is reduced
and repulsive energy
is probably enhanced,
because instead of having
your atoms spread out,
they're bunched up
at each lattice site
into a higher density cloud.
So anyway, maybe you're
interested in parity
potentials, or you're
interested in quantum systems
with strong correlations.
For whatever reasons, you
want optical lattices.
Now I have here a
few slides which
introduce periodic
potentials, but it is really
just the single particle
physics in a periodic potential.
It has nothing do
with quantum gases.
This could be the
first lecture of how
to describe
electrons in a metal.
So let me just quickly
go through assuming
that almost all of
you are familiar.
But I use those slides also just
to give you a few definitions
and introduce a few symbols.
So this is simple, boring,
exactly understood physics.
We have a Hamiltonian
which has kinetic energy,
and a periodic potential which
is our lattice potential.
It's rather trivial to solve,
but exactly for your wave
function, you use
Bloch's theorem
and divide it by an exponential
factor with quasi momentum
times a periodic function.
And if you now solve
Schrodinger's equation,
you want to use Fourier space.
You Fourier analyze
the wave function.
the potential.
And since the
potential is periodic,
sine square potential has
only three Fourier components
at 0 plus/minus 1 times the
periodicity of the lattice.
You do a Fourier expansion for
your periodic wave function.
And if you insert that into
Schrodinger's equation,
well, the Fourier transform
has turned the differential
equation into an
algebraic equation,
because the second
derivative simply
becomes now k
squared or q squared.
So in other words, you have
a set of linear equations.
There is an index
which is the band
index-- how high
do you want to go?
And usually you truncate it.
But it's the same.
It is that same
trivial story which
is told in all textbooks of
condensed matter physics.
If you have no band structure,
well, you have the parabola,
but to prepare for
band structure,
I've opened it down here in
the first Brillouin zone.
And if you now
introduce a lattice,
you introduce band gaps, and you
go from the left to the middle
to the right for stronger
and stronger lattices.
So the case which
I will focus on,
because it is the most extreme
case away from free space,
is this case which is called
the tight binding limit, where
the potential energy of
the lattice is large.
And large means compared
with the kinetic energy
at the Brillouin
Zone, which is k
squared-- k is the lattice
momentum-- k squared over 2 m.
And that's the recoil energy.
So that our dimensionless
parameter here
is the depth of the
lattice measured
in recoil energies
of the photon,
because that is
the kinetic energy
of the free gas at
the Brillouin zone.
OK there are few things which
immediately simplify that.
Once we're in the
tight binding limit,
our lattice is really
deep, and each side
forms a harmonic oscillator.
And the harmonic
oscillator frequency
is analytically given by
the depth of the lattice.
And the solution here
for the lowest band
is that the lowest
band-- the energy
in the lowest band, the
dispersion relation is-- well,
we have a harmonic oscillator
in each site at x y z.
So the average energy
in the lowest band
is the 0 point energy in x, y,
and z-- three half h-bar omega
0.
And then we have a
cosinusoidal band structure
where q is the quasimomentum.
And what appears here as the
only interesting parameter
is j.
And j is I think this 4
should be 4j is the bandwidth.
So what appears here now
for the first time is j.
It appears here
as the bandwidth.
But let me immediately give
it another interpretation
as a tunneling matrix element in
the following way-- right now,
we have formulated the physics
in Bloch wave functions
which are infinitely extended.
The Bloch wave functions
are for the lattice
what plain waves
are for free space.
But if you have
tight binding limit,
there is another limit
which is important.
Namely, a particle is localized
and hops around in the lattice.
The localized particle, of
course, is in free space.
It would be a wave packet-- a
superposition of plain waves.
So let's do the
same in the lattice.
Let's construct
superpositions of Bloch waves.
And these are our wave packets.
And the wave packet is now
called the Wannier function.
And there is a
mathematical procedure
how you should pick
the phases here
to get the maximal
normalization.
But the simple picture is
those Wannier functions are
very, very close to the
Gaussian ground state
solution of the harmonic
oscillator on each side.
The wings are different, but
I don't want to go into that.
You transform from an
orthonormal basis of Bloch wave
function to another orthonormal
basis Wannier function.
And the Wannier functions are
as well localized as possible.
That's the procedure.
And now we can simply
rewrite our total Hamiltonian
or everything we're interested
in, not in Bloch wave functions
but in Wannier wave functions.
And what comes out now is,
is that the bandwidth j
is nothing else than our
Hamiltonian with kinetic energy
in the periodic potential.
But j becomes now
a matrix element
between two Wannier functions.
But the Wannier
functions have now-- I'll
put in some indices
in a moment--
connect now two different sides.
So it is-- you have
Wannier function.
You have the Hamiltonian
and connect it
to another Wannier function.
So it is the amplitude
that, with the Hamiltonian,
the particle can hop from
one side to another side.
So therefore j, which
was the bandwidth,
is now the tunneling
energy divided
by h bar-- the tunneling
rate from on one side
to the other side.
For very deep lattice,
everything is analytic
and it can easily be solved.
And I mentioned already in the
tight binding approximation,
you should think about
your Wannier function
as just localized
Gaussian eigensolutions
of the harmonic oscillator.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So qualitatively, this
question sounds sort of silly,
but normally when we write
down the solution for j,
we're only considering
nearest neighbor.
But from the math,
I don't immediately
see why we wouldn't
include i equal to j.
PROFESSOR: Give
me one more slide.
So I should've
actually-- what I should
have done is that--
j has an index here.
I just didn't want to
overload you with indices.
I mean, this is sort
of just telling you
what j is in its simplest form.
It is loaded with indices and
I well show you in a moment
where those indices come in.
So I just wanted to
give you the idea
if we want to have
Wannier function.
We hop from one Wannier
function to the other one,
and the operator
is the Hamiltonian.
And therefore, there
should be an index j and l.
And maybe-- let me just do the
next step first and then come
back to it, but I
wanted to tell you here
what I'm aiming at--
namely interpretation of j,
of tunneling from
one side to the next.
But right now I haven't really
told you which j I really mean.
There should be-- based
on the right-hand side,
there is a j which
has two indices.
And I will make the indices
disappear in a moment.
But before I make those
indices disappear,
let me introduce the other
relevant parameter, which
will also have
indices, and that is we
have to bring in
the interactions.
We want to describe
an interacting system.
We describe an
interacting system
using the short-range
approximation
by assuming that two particles
interact with a delta function.
And if you have two particles
on site, each of them
has a density which is the
Wannier function squared.
And the product of the
two densities integrated
gives us the expectation value
for the repulsive energy.
And this is given here.
So the moment we
introduce interactions,
we are now interested in
the interaction energy
between two particles which in
this case occupy the same side.
OK so I've tried to introduce
was what sort of j is.
j is a matrix element
between two Wannier functions
with a Hamiltonian in between.
And u is the matrix element
of two Wannier functions
with the interaction
operator in between.
And now I want to
use that concept
to take my full
Hamiltonian and transform
from field operators localized
at x to Wannier functions.
So they B operators are
now creation operators.
They create an atom
in a Wannier function.
In other words, B
dagger means you
have a particle in a
Wannier function at site i.
And I just use that as
a basis transformation
and the exact transformation
of this Hamiltonian
is now into this form.
So
What I have right now is, I have
the tunneling matrix element
between particles
at site i and j,
and I have to sum
over all of them.
And in terms of interaction,
I can calculate this matrix
element by using Wannier
function with four
different indices
and ask what happens.
And this is simply an
exact way of rewriting it.
And here I've given
you the definition.
So if you want to
forget everything
I told you about j and u, I've
done an exact transformation
from field operators to Wannier
function creation operators.
And this introduces tunneling
terms like this from site i
to site j.
And these here includes products
of four Wannier functions
which are responsible
for the interaction term.
Actually, if this is
not complicated enough,
I've suppressed
band indices here.
I should also now sum
over all possible bands.
But OK, I want to come now
to the leading approximation
in a tight binding model.
And that is where--
I mean those Wannier
functions are overlapped.
Two neighboring Wannier
functions barely overlap.
If I go further away, the
overlap becomes even smaller.
So the most dominant terms are
nearest neighbor interactions.
And the nearest
neighbor interaction
is where i and j differ by 1.
And this is what I
call j without indices.
And similarly, when it comes
to the interaction term
where we have products
of four Wannier functions
and we want to get the
overlap of all four,
and then multiply it with g,
the prefactor of our delta
function to get an
interaction term,
well the best overlap is if
all indices are the same.
And this is what I call U.
So in that limit, in
that tight binding limit,
my Hamiltonian is
now very simple.
It consists of a tunneling
term parametrized with j,
and an on site interaction
term parametrized with U. Yes.
AUDIENCE: So you're saying
i, j and k are all the same,
so the interaction
is with itself?
PROFESSOR: No, two
particles per site.
When the four
particles are the same,
it turns into-- this
Hamiltonian here has
all indices are the same.
And if you calculate that, it
turns into the product of 2 b.
b dagger is the occupation
number at each site.
But if you're careful
with commutators,
it becomes occupation number
times occupation number
minus 1.
If you have only one particle
per site, this term is 0.
So technically U is, if
you put in 2 times 1,
if you have two
particles per site,
U is the interaction energy
between two particles.
Just use this
expression to figure out
what it is for three or four.
But for one particle, you get 0.
The self interaction of a
particle is absolutely 0.
One particle does not
interact with itself.
AUDIENCE: That gets back to my
question with the [INAUDIBLE].
So when you have i equals j, the
[INAUDIBLE] term, do you just--
PROFESSOR: No, I assume,
i j is nearest neighbor.
I assume that the index
i and j differ by 1.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I mean your
argument was that the best
overlap is between
nearest neighbors.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So an overlap
with the Wannier functions
at the same site is sort
of the kinetic energy term.
Is it approximately 0,
or you just absorb that
into the chemical potential?
PROFESSOR: This is a 0.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
So we're only
looking at nearest neighbor,
so are we essentially saying
the case where i equals j is
approximately 0 [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE 2: Because
it's the matrix element
of a Hamiltonian.
So p, the candidate, plus
the lattice operator.
So if I take my
Wannier function,
which is built out of
eigenvalues for that equation,
[INAUDIBLE] bunch
of energy terms.
On every site [INAUDIBLE]
they're the same.
Because you have a common
[INAUDIBLE] energy that you can
[INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Well then just
multiple it by [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: My gut
feeling is-- and this
is why nobody considers
it-- it's just
a constant energy, which is
probably something like the 0
point energy times the number
of particles, which is not
affecting any dynamics.
It's pretty much a constant
which can be simply dropped.
Let me just go
back to that slide.
I hope-- let me just
look up the reference.
I haven't looked at it recently.
When we do this
exact transformation,
there should be a
reference whether i
and j, what happens
when i equals j.
I think it's just
a constant term.
AUDIENCE: Because
if you're summing
over every single
lattice site, so
you get the number of
particles times 0 [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, but
even mathematically
it gives just a constant term,
here, which is [INAUDIBLE].
Thanks.
It was good to clarify it.
OK, I think within
the next 20 minutes,
I can step you through
the superfluid to Mott
insulator transition.
First, references for what
I've just said are given here.
But let me now come take
this Bose-Hubbard model
and discuss its
two limiting cases.
One case is where U
is much larger than j.
The other case is where
j is much larger than U.
These are the two
limiting cases,
and it will turn out
that one is an insulator
and one is a superfluid.
And that makes perfect
sense, of course.
If U is much larger than
j, I can set j equals to 0
if I can neglect it.
No tunneling means no transport,
and that means an insulator.
It's also clear that when
there is no tunneling,
that the system is
really described
by a product of so and so
many particles per site.
So it could be one
particle per site.
And I have a product
over all sites,
or two particles per site.
So this will be
the ground state.
And it's called the ground
state of the Mott insulator.
It's also trivial
to discuss what
happens if j is much,
much larger than U,
because then I simply neglect
U, and I have a free gas.
Well, a free gas of
Bloch wave function,
but that's the same as a free
gas of planar wave function.
It's just that quasimomentum
replaces momentum.
And if you have just
an ideal Bose gas
in a periodic lattice instead
of Bose-Einstein condensation
in the lowest
momentum state, you
have Bose-Einstein condensation
in the lowest quasimomentum
state.
The lowest quasimomentum
state is a superposition
of all Wannier
function-- I mean,
the 0 momentum
state in free space
is a superposition of all
position delta functions.
The plane wave is delocalized.
And the lowest
quasimomentum state
is just completely delocalized
over all Wannier functions.
But this is nothing
else than the q
equals 0 quasimomentum
Bloch wave.
The interesting
question is-- and this
has led to hundreds if not
more papers in the literature--
how do we go from one
limit to the other limit?
And now you would
say, well, maybe we
should use what
has worked so well.
We should use the
Bogoliubov approximation.
Just assume we
have a condensate,
replace all those kind of a 0
operators for the lowest Bloch
waves.
However, this doesn't work,
because the interesting thing
here is to find the
transition from the superfluid
from the Bose-Einstein
condensate
to an insulating state.
The nature of this
approximation is
that you need N 0 to be large.
But we're interested when the
condensate wave function turns
to 0, and in the
insulator it becomes 0.
So we are actually interested
in the opposite limit.
And indeed, if you
would ignore everything
I've just said that
doesn't make sense
to make this approximation
and make it nevertheless,
you will find that you never
get the insulating state
because you've pretty much
eliminated the possibility
to describe an insulating state
by doing this approximation.
So I want to show
you now that we
have to do another mean
field approximation, which
is actually nice.
It's very different from this
Bogoliubov approximation,
but it's also a mean
field approximation
which will describe our system.
So the goal is now
that I want to find
an effective Hamiltonian
which describes
the transition
from here to there.
And the important
approximation I will use
was is the following-- again,
I have to get rid of operators.
Products of two many
operators cannot be solved.
And so what I will do is I
will use products of operators,
write them as average
value plus fluctuations.
And then when I
multiply that out,
I take the product of
the average values,
and I include the
fluctuations in leading order.
So I take delta A times B
and delta B times A average,
but I neglect the product
of those fluctuations.
You can say I neglect the
correlation of fluctuations
here.
So this is spelled out here.
But the sign is important.
Just look at this equation--
A delta B plus delta B with B
plus A average times B average.
If I absorb A times B by
upgrading delta B to B,
but I do the same here,
I have to subtract
1 product of the
two average values.
It's actually this minus sign
which will play a role later,
but here you see already that
I will make this decoupling
approximation-- that I
decouple the fluctuations
from each other and I
write it in this way,
there is an
important minus sign.
OK, so we want to start
in the insulating state.
And we're going to figure out
how does the system develop
superfluidity out of
the insulation state?
And the perturbation
operator which takes me out
of the insulating
state is tunneling.
So therefore, the operator which
is responsible for breaking out
of the insulating
state is the operator
which induces tunneling
between neighboring sites.
And the tunneling operator
in this Hamiltonian--
remember, the Bose-Hubbard
model had j times B dagger B--
this was our tunneling
term-- this involves now
products of operators.
And I told you we want to get
rid of products of operators
to get something we
can easily solve.
So we use now this
product of operators
on two neighboring sites.
And we use exactly this
decoupling approximation.
So therefore, we replace each
operator by an average value,
and we neglect the product
of the fluctuations.
And then we obtain this.
And I explained to you where
the minus sign came from.
So now I call this average
value of the operator B l,
I call the superfluid
order parameter psi.
I think I could have
chosen psi to be complex,
and then B l dagger B l
would have complex conjugate.
But it's sufficient here
to restrict the discussion
on real numbers, and it
makes the notation simpler.
So anyway, I introduce that.
And what happens now
is the following--
that I have my Hamiltonian.
The Hamiltonian had
the interaction energy.
But the tunneling term
is now very simplified,
because instead of
tunneling from one site
to a neighboring
site, the other side
is sort of absorbed
by the mean field,
by the superfluid
order parameter psi.
And therefore, and this
here gives me a psi
squared term which appears here.
Trust me, this is just
an identical rewrite
of the previous Hamiltonian
by using this decoupling
approximation.
So what we have gained now
is something really dramatic.
We had many sites and
tunneling from site to site.
But if you look at
it now, we simply sum
the effective Hamiltonian
over site index l.
So our effective
Hamiltonian is now
the sum of an identical
Hamiltonian per site.
The sites no longer
interact with each other.
Each site interacts with all
the other sites described
by the mean field by the
superfluid order parameter psi.
So therefore, our
many-body problem,
which is still a
but has turned into an effective
Hamiltonian for each site,
because each side has
the same Hamiltonian.
Colin.
AUDIENCE: What happened
to the j psi squared term?
PROFESSOR: This here?
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
PROFESSOR: OK so I can say
instead of solving for the sum,
I can just solve for
each site individually.
And this is now my effective
Hamiltonian for each site.
Now I want to catch the
onset of superfluidity.
So I want to get the
system when psi is small.
And therefore, I can just
ask-- I don't know what psi is.
It's part of my solution.
But I'm interested
in the moment when
psi begins to take off from
0, when superfluidity emerges.
So what I can therefore do is,
I can regard psi as an epsilon
parameter, as a small parameter.
And the psi parameter
comes with an operator V.
And this operator V is nothing
else than B l dagger plus B l.
So in other words,
what I'm doing is,
I'm separating my Hamiltonian
into a Hamiltonian which
is diagonal in the
quantum numbers
of the isolating state--
just one, two, three
particles per site.
And psi squared is the Z number.
Psi squared is also
diagonal in that.
And now the possibility
of tunneling,
the possibility of
superfluidity is now
perturbative in this
term psi times V.
OK, I don't want to explain,
actually, this expression.
It just formalizes
[INAUDIBLE] intermediate step.
When we have the
chemical potential,
and we raise the
chemical potential--
we go from zero to
one particle per site
to two particles per site.
And whatever the
chemical potential is
determines whether we have
one or two particles per site.
This is just telling me as a
function of chemical potential,
what is the ground
state of the insulator?
So now we take this ground
state-- it's actually
much easier described
in words then
by this formula-- we
take this ground state
and do perturbation theory in
our term psi times V. Remember,
the operator is B dagger
B. And the epsilon is psi.
So in second-order perturbation
theory, we get psi squared.
And then V, because B B
dagger, is very simple.
It only couples one occupation
number N to N plus 1
and N minus 1,
because B and B dagger
destroy or create a
particle per site.
So therefore, I can
immediately write down
what this matrix element is
in second-order perturbation
theory.
I mean, these are all--
sorry, it's all defined here.
I know I'm losing you now.
Nobody will tell me what is the
difference between U bar and U,
but it's trivially defined.
So the idea is we have
the isolating system.
We do perturbation
theory in tunneling.
And the perturbative operator
is psi times B plus B dagger.
The B plus B dagger
matrix elements
are trivial, because
they admix to N particles
per site-- N plus
1 and N minus 1.
And this is what
we've done here.
AUDIENCE: And the j is
just occupation number?
PROFESSOR: The j is the
occupation number of our site.
AUDIENCE: I have two questions.
So in the bottom equation, what
happened to the psi squared?
PROFESSOR: Sorry,
this is the sum.
The psi square is missing.
AUDIENCE: I guess I
had the same question
for the equation next
to the green thing.
Is there supposed to be
a psi squared in there?
Because originally, there's
a psi squared and an h0.
PROFESSOR: No, this is the
ground state where psi is 0.
And now we do
perturbation theory
in psi V. These are the
unperturbed energies which
appear in the
energy denominator.
The wave functions
we are using are
Fock states-- number
states-- per site.
And here we couple occupation
number j to all possible N's.
But because of B and B dagger,
N has only two values--
j plus 1 and j minus 1.
And this is what's given here.
It's mathematically trivial.
The notation is more complicated
than the physics behind it.
But now comes again-- I think I
need five minutes and I'm done.
But now comes the
interesting physics.
We have to ask what
are we doing here?
It's all the mathematical, and
the math is really simple here.
What we have done is we have
looked at the isolating state,
and we have done perturbation
theory in psi times B plus B
dagger.
And now we get an
energy correction
which is psi squared.
And what are we
really doing here?
Well, you can say
the following--
we started with a
hypothesis that we
have a superfluid state
characterized by psi and psi,
at the onset of
superfluidity-- is small.
But now we have
done the calculation
assuming that there is a psi.
But now we are turning around
and said have we really
done the system a favor by
introducing superfluidity?
In other words, has our
perturbation theory in psi
lowered the energy of
the state or raised
the energy of the state.
So in other words, we've done
a hypothetical calculation.
Hey, what would the
system feel like if there
were a little bit
of superfluidity?
If the system says great,
I've lowered my energy,
then we know we are in
the superfluid state.
When the system says no,
I raised my energy because
of the psi, then the system
has rejected our idea
to introduce superfluidity.
So therefore, the question
we are raising now
is after we have done the
calculation, for what values
of U and j is it favorable
to introduce a psi or not?
Now I was expecting the
question of some of you
that in second-order
perturbation theory,
second-order perturbation
theory always lowers the energy.
But remember, this is why I
emphasized the minus sign--
we had a psi squared term
which came from that, which
came from the last term of the
decoupling approximation, which
had a minus sign.
And therefore, we
have in psi squared
one term which came
from this special psi--
and I emphasized in the
decoupling approximation.
And we have a contribution
of psi squared
which comes from
perturbation theory.
And the two together can
actually change their sign.
So what we have right now is
if you describe the ground
state as a function of psi,
we have our unperturbed energy
of the Mott insulating
states, and then we
have a term in psi squared.
And we should-- and we could,
but we don't-- calculate
the next order in
psi to the four.
And it turns out in fourth-order
perturbation theory,
this term is always positive.
So what happens now
to the total energy
when this term A2, which we
have exactly analytically
calculated-- if this term A2
is larger or smaller than 0.
Well, if you have a parabolic
term and a quartic term,
in this case, both the
quadratic and the quartic term
are opening up
like in a U shape,
but here the total energy
turns into W shape.
And the interpretation
is fairly simple.
Under those
conditions, the system
prefers to have psi equal
0, whereas here, it's
like the system wants to
have a psi parameter which
is finite, either
positive or negative.
And whether it's
positive or negative
is sometimes called
spontaneous symmetry breaking
between two
degenerate solutions.
What I'm showing
here is, of course,
very similar to the
Ginzburg-Landau theory
of phase transitions, where
you have an effective potential
and the phase transition
takes place when
the second-order
coefficient changes sign,
and the effective potential
turns from U-shaped
into W-shaped.
So that's what we have done.
So anyway, I think this
is a nice problem where
the interpretation
is, I think, much more
subtle than the
calculation itself.
But we've calculated
the phase transition.
Everything is analytic.
Here is the analytic
result, which
I know with very
indigestible notation.
I followed exactly the paper
by Vanderstraeten, [? Stouff ?]
and collaborators, which
is posted on the website.
You can plot this phase
diagram in this way.
But if you use what
is more common,
normalize the chemical potential
by U and normalize j by U,
you get these wonderful
lobes of the Mott insulator
where you see that,
if you increase
the chemical potential, you
have N equals 1, N equals 2,
N equals 3, Mott insulator,
and in between you
go through superfluid regions.
However if your
tunneling is larger,
if your tunneling is too
large, you're only superfluid.
So this is sort
of the way how you
derive this rather
rich phase diagram
of bosonic atoms in
an optical lattice.
Green is an insulating state.
And white is the
superfluid state.
Let me just conclude by
showing a few slides how
this can be observed.
So in one case, we have
an insulating state
with a definite number
of particles per site.
And here we have
superfluid state,
which has the normal
fluctuations in number.
Here's another cartoon picture
of an condensate in the lowest
Bloch wave function.
And here you have
localized number states.
Often, you observe the
transition by taking the system
and releasing it
in time of flight
into ballistic expansion.
If the superfluidity
is coherent,
the wave function on the
different sites is coherent.
And what you get is a
multi-slit interference pattern,
which is a diffraction pattern.
And you see these characteristic
diffraction patterns.
It's an in-slit
diffraction pattern
which characterizes the
coherence in the initial state.
However if you have a
completely isolating state,
you have a Gaussian wave
packet on each side, which
has nothing to do with
the next neighbor.
And then the Gaussian
wave function simply
expands in a structureless way.
And so the transition
from here to there
happens exactly when
the ratio of U over j
crosses the value
we have derived.
There's another
technique of observing
that which is more recent.
This is a quantum
gas microscopes
where you do the same
physics in two dimensions,
so you have only one plane
where this physics takes place.
And you can observe atoms
now with a microscope.
So each green dot
here is an atom.
If you sort of zoom in.
And if you now study
the region where
you go through the superfluid
to the Mott insulator,
you see that you have
exactly one atom per site.
If you increase the atom
number, you have an insulator
with one atom per site.
And in the middle,
you have state
with two atoms per site,
which-- for reasons
I don't want to discuss-- are
color-coded here in black.
And that sort of
goes on and goes on.
So you can really
resolve site per site
the occupation of the
number of atoms per site.
So I think I'll stop
here with the Bose gases.
When you think the
Mott insulator is
the end of the story, all
motion has been frozen out
and you have one
particle per site, well,
it could be the
beginning of a new story.
Because if you use two
different hyperfine states,
spin up and spin down, we
can talk about spin ordering.
But this would be a
whole different lecture.